Hello game developers, and
welcome back to another thrill
a minute episode of Game On.
So if you're paying attention
to Google I/O this year,
you might have noticed
that in addition
to all those Android powered
watches, and cars, and TVs,
and blenders and stuff,
we launched a major update
to the Play Games service.
In addition to exciting
features like quests
and save games-- which I will
talk about in future episodes
I promise-- every user now
has their very own game
profile which they
level up as they play.
This game profile will be
visible throughout the Play
Games experience.
Players will see it
as soon as they're
signed in to any game
using game services.
It's the first thing they
see in the Play Games app,
and the players can
compare their game profile
with that of their friends.
And at every point
along the way,
we're showing players what
level their profile is at.
Here I can see that
I'm at level 15,
while my manager Rado
is only at level 7.
Clearly my manager,
he's a bit of a slacker.
And so with all the
work we're going
to be doing raising the
visibility of this game profile
level, I think
it's safe to assume
this is the metric by which
most people will start measuring
their contribution to society,
and overall value as a person.
Or at the very least,
it's something a lot
of your players, particularly
the competitive ones,
are going to care about.
So how do players level
up their game profile?
By unlocking XP.
And how to get this XP?
By earning achievements.
We convert achievement
points to XP
by using a fairly complicated
formula that I don't want
to get into right now,
because it's a lot of math.
And uh, oh, actually
it's just this.
Every point you decide
an achievement is worth,
it's roughly equal to 100
XP in the Play Games app.
So as players start caring
about their game profile level,
they're going to start caring
about how much XP they earn.
And as players care
about the XP they earn,
they're going to care
about the achievements
you put in your game, and
how much they are worth.
So use these achievements well,
and score them appropriately,
and they can be a powerful
force to keep players
happy and engaged
within your game.
So let's talk about making
sure these achievements
are scored correctly.
And that starts by having a
decent number of achievements.
We took a look at our
100 top performing games
with achievements, and
found that they average
about 30 or 40
achievements per title.
So put in a good
assortment of achievements.
Once you have that, you
then have the freedom
to add in a mix of achievement
difficulties, right?
Variety is the spice of
life, maybe after salt.
So you want to add some
tough achievements that
might take players some
extra effort to earn,
as well as a few easy ones
that players will earn just
in the natural course
of playing your game.
Once you've done
that, you can now
score these things
appropriately.
We recommend make the easy ones
worth around 5 to 20 points,
the medium ones about 25
to 45, and the hard to epic
ones in the 50 to
100 point range.
Now remember, you have a maximum
of 1,000 achievement points
per game.
So if you're making a game
with 100 achievements,
you're going to
need to score them
a lower on average than
our recommendations.
But that's OK, a lot of
achievements, that's fun too.
Also keep in mind that if you've
got some future expansions
planned for your game, and you
have achievements to go along
with each of these new
expansions-- and you should--
don't use up all your
points right away.
Keep a few in reserve,
so that you then
have some achievements
points to spend
on each of these new updates.
But what do you do
if you've created
what you think is a
little one off project,
and it becomes a surprise hit?
Well good problem
to have I guess,
but now you want to
add more updates,
and you want to add
more achievements
with those updates.
But you've already used
up your 1,000 points.
So now what?
Well it turns out we
do give you the ability
to change point values
of your achievements
even after they
have been published.
So you can reduce the
value of some of your older
achievements, and then
you have a few more points
to spend on the new ones.
Now if you do this,
your current players,
they're going to get to
keep the points they've
earned for their
older achievements.
So that means your most loyal
fans, who maybe earned 1,000
points from your
original release,
they're going to be able to
earn more than 1,000 achievement
points total.
Which in the grand
scheme of things
isn't so bad-- you're rewarding
your most loyal players--
but don't do it
too often or it'll
start get confusing if
players notice that they're
getting scored differently
than their friends.
Second, double check that
your achievements are, well,
achievable.
Have you gone and made
five secret achievements
that nobody can actually earn?
Yes, we know who you are.
And in fact, if
you've done this,
you've probably seen that
we now hide the achievements
portion of your game
in the Play Games app.
And maybe your players noticed
earlier, and didn't care much.
Because it's a bummer
to not get achievements,
but it's not the
end of the world.
But now this means they can't
level up by playing your game.
And maybe they decide
to ditch your game
in favor of something similar
that will increase their level.
Maybe that's not a
risk you want to take.
Just a thought.
But on the flip
side, you also need
to watch out for giving away
too many achievements too early.
Watch out for making
your achievements so easy
that they earned in the first
30 seconds of your game.
Partly, this is a big missed
opportunity for you, the game
developer, because you've
used up all your achievements
before your player has
had a chance to really
become invested in your game.
But also, if you give away
too many points too quickly,
it may trigger some rate
limiting alarms on our end,
and you might find that your
achievements aren't worth
as much as they ought to be.
So remember, it's OK to
have easy achievements,
but they should be
ones the players earn
through the course of naturally
playing your game, not ones
they are just by pressing
the Start button,
or finishing level one.
Finally, you might have
noticed that we not only tell
each player the amount
of XP they've earned,
but we break it down
by game category.
Here you can see that I'm
clearly a puzzle player,
as shown by my title Puzzler.
While my friend
Damien, you can see
he's a little more
of a racing player.
And our official
titles are based
on the games we've earned
the most points in.
So my last piece
of advice for you
game developers is make sure
you have your games category
set correctly in two places.
Yes, two.
Both here in the
Play Store listing,
which you've probably
already done,
but also here in the game
services detail page.
Yes, you need to set it twice.
Once is for the Play Store, and
the other is for game services
to use for the
user's game profile.
So this will make sure we're not
recommending your match three
game to a bunch of racing
fans, and we'll also make sure
that players won't level up
as a music game aficionado
by playing your first
person zombie shooter.
So there you have it, folks.
The new game profile is on
an Android device near you,
and is going to sweep
across the nation
like a stampede of
majestic wild ostriches.
Now you can harness
this stampede
and ride it to fame and glory.
or wind up with a bunch of
talon marks on your face.
It's up to you, your
fate is in your hands.
Just remember.
One, create a varieties
of achievement
and set their scores
appropriately.
Two, don't do the five
secret achievements
that nobody can
actually earn thing.
That's not cool.
And three, set your
games category correctly.
So thanks for tuning in.
You keep making great games,
and we'll keep playing them.
Now if you'll excuse me, I've
got a "Flappy Bird" clone
that I'm trying to port
to my Android blender.
So I gotta get to work.